PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Deconstructing Chat Bots.
I am Priyanka Vergadia
and in today's episode,
I have a very special guest
from Conversation Design team
at Google, Cathy Pearl.
Thank you, Cathy,
for being here.
CATHY PEARL: Thanks
so much for having me.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK, Cathy,
so what is conversation design?
What is your role at Google?
CATHY PEARL: So I'm the Head of
Conversation Design Outreach,
which is a bit of a
mouthful, but basically it
means I tell people
both inside Google
and outside in the world
about conversation design,
what it is, and
why it's important.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So what the
heck is conversation design?
CATHY PEARL: At
a high level, you
can think of it as
we're teaching computers
to communicate more like humans
and not the other way around.
And you know, a lot of us have
had frustrating experiences
with our voices systems.
I don't know if you've ever
had a frustrating experience.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
A ton of times.
How do we avoid them?
CATHY PEARL: A lot
of times, people
think it's a technical
problem, but in fact, it's
often because design best
practices were not followed.
So we want to make sure that
when people are building
these things, if you follow
good design principles,
you're much more likely to
have a successful experience.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
I am a developer,
so I really don't
write design things.
Where do I get started?
CATHY PEARL: We
always recommend you
start with something
pretty straightforward
called a sample dialogue.
It's basically like
a movie script.
It's a back and forth between
your user and your system.
And it really helps you
kind of flesh out your ideas
and make sure you're going
in the right direction.
And you just write these down.
And I always tell
people, don't worry.
They really don't have to
be perfect, especially right
out of the gate.
Mine are certainly not perfect
when I first write them down.
But over time, just
remember that old rule,
there's no great writing,
there's only great rewriting.
And after you've
written some, you
do just like you do in
Hollywood with a movie script,
you do a table read.
You read them out loud.
So you find a willing
victim, and then you
have them play the
part of the user.
And you just take
turns reading out loud.
And you'll be surprised.
You'll actually find a
lot of problems and issues
with your design just through
that alone, before you've
written a single line of code.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So, Cathy, I know
how to have a conversation.
Why do I have to
design a conversation
before I start working?
CATHY PEARL: I think
a lot of people
are used to designing for things
like mobile apps or websites
where when somebody
taps a button
or swipes or selects a menu
item, you know what they chose.
And if you're designing
a conversational system,
whether it's voice
or typing, people
are going to say
all kinds of things
that you're not going expect.
And part of conversation
design is really
guiding people to
success by showing them
the types of things they're
going to be able to say,
in order for you to
be able to respond.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK, so I
get that I need to learn more
about conversation design,
but if I write my prompts
correctly, then do you think
everything else will just
follow?
CATHY PEARL: The
better you write
your prompts and your
flow, the more likely
you are going to get
answers you can respond to.
But the big thing I
always tell people
is when you're working with
conversational experiences,
people will always say
things you didn't expect.
And that's just kind of human.
I mean, when we're
talking, we often
don't understand
every single word
that the other person says.
But we don't say
oh, we had errors.
That's because we're so
good at what we call repair.
We repair our conversations
very gracefully
and we get back on track.
So that's the kind
of strategy you
want to apply to your
conversational systems.
If you can repair
things gracefully
when people say things
you don't expect,
because that will happen, then
you can get them back on track
and keep going.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Can you walk me
through some of the
examples of how you
would repair a conversation?
CATHY PEARL: Yeah, so if
somebody says things--
says something your
system didn't expect,
one quick thing is just to
rephrase the options that are
available at that current time.
You definitely don't want
to say like, I didn't
understand, or say that again.
You're not helping
the person, right?
You're trying to get
through your experience
and you're just,
you're abandoning them.
So one way is to just sort of
rephrase the current options.
Not all the things
they can possibly
do, but just like, right now
what should they be focused on?
Another part of that is
called rapid reprompt.
So that's just a really
fast way to do that.
So let's say you're writing
a chocolate recipe bot,
and you ask, do you like milk
chocolate or dark chocolate?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Milk chocolate.
CATHY PEARL: And the person
says, 65%, which maybe we
don't understand that.
So a rapid reprompt would
be, sorry, was that milk
chocolate or dark chocolate?
And that will get
people back on track.
And one other thing I want
to say about error handling
or repair is a lot of
time, that first rephrasing
or rapid reprompt will
get people right back on
and going again, but if they
have a second error right away,
there's probably not
enough information
for them to know what
to do or what to say.
So at that point, you might
want to have something
a little bit longer with a
little more detail, like oh,
your account number is
on the upper left hand
corner of your bill,
or something like that.
Because they're struggling
at that point and you just
really want to help them out.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK,
so what I'm understanding
is don't just say, I
didn't get that, right.
Just try to be a little
bit more specific
about what was it that
you were expecting
and how can the user
get back on track.
CATHY PEARL: Exactly.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That's actually
very interesting
and amazing advice.
We are seeing a lot of smart
displays coming into being.
What are your
recommendations for designing
for those smart displays?
CATHY PEARL: Yeah, I'm
really excited to see
some of these different ways
that people can interact.
And I think smart
displays in particular,
there's going to be a
lot of interesting things
that people come up with.
What we advise is
to always start
designing the voice-only
experience first,
which might seem a
little counterintuitive.
But in fact, the
voice-only experience
is often the most
constrained and complex.
I'll give you an example.
Let's say you're just
writing about business hours.
And if you're thinking about
a mobile phone experience,
if I'm asking you, you know,
what time is Sushi King open?
You can just pop up
a card on the phone
and it has, Monday 10 to 6,
Tuesday 11 to 7, or whatever.
But if I just ask on a
smart speaker and I say,
what time is it open today?
If you started saying, Monday
it's open 6:00 AM to 7:00 PM.
Tuesday it's open--
I mean, that's just like
ugh, way too much, right?
So instead, you want
to craft the prompt
just like a human would,
to answer just the question
itself.
So if I say, is
it open right now?
That's a yes/no question.
You should start with yes or no.
If I say, you know, what time
does it open on Wednesday?
It opens on Wednesday at 11:00.
And you'll find you might have
to write dozens of prompts
to handle that, when on a mobile
phone, it's only one card.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
What would be some of your
final pieces of advice
for our viewers today?
CATHY PEARL: Well,
first I'm just
really excited to see
what kind of experiences
you all come up with
that are going to be
really interesting to see.
I also think that voice
has really matured
in the accessibility realm.
I think we're finally
seeing examples
where voice
technology can really
help people who might
have motor impairments
or visual impairments or
even cognitive impairments.
And I think this just
brings us into the idea
of inclusive design, which
means we're not just designing
for this person or
that person, but really
designing for all of us.
I mean, if you think
about it, we all
have impairments
from time to time.
Situational impairments, like,
I'm carrying the groceries in
and I can't use my hands, or
I forgot my reading glasses
and I really want to
read this text message.
So being able to use my
voice is really handy there.
Or maybe I fall and break my
arm or something like that.
So I'm just excited to see that
voice technology has really
risen more to the
challenge of helping people
who really need it the most.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
Thanks, Cathy.
This was awesome.
I really learned a lot about
conversation design today.
CATHY PEARL: Thanks
for having me.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Thank you, everybody,
for watching this show.
I hope that you guys liked
Cathy's recommendations
and apply some of those in
your conversation designs.
And if you would
like to learn more,
go to actions.google.com/design.
Well, I didn't design the sample
dialogue for this conversation,
so we have to do take two.
CATHY PEARL: Take three.
That's a wrap.